if you are a real Daredevil you can take
to the skies with a paraglide that's
right well it's a sport gaming of course
popularity across the entire country and
even right here in southern Nevada Ryan
Matthew shows us what's up
it's a bird it's a plane it's
paragliders it's what they call butt
face
powered paragliding an ultralight
backpack motor Landing here in the
valley Ray Walker is one of only a
handful of instructors in Las Vegas
flying is easy it's just it's just two
breaks in your hands you know left and
right it's really easy to do and you got
a throttle one two three a sport anyone
can do with a week of training that is a
tank of gas keeping flyers in the air
for up to five hours called the cheapest
and safest form of Aviation it's drawing
adventurers near and far gotta keep
moving got a destination to get to like
Caleb Johnson who made the truck here
from Northern California feels like
you're flying like a bird or maybe like
a roller coaster I'm living the life of
my dreams and Miroslav sveg from
Slovakia just having the ability to see
everything as close up as as you would
be hiking there but you are hiking at
the 40 miles per hour speed nearly 20 T
of these power paragliders touching down
to south of Boulder City feeling up
before heading back out to Utah a day's
long adventure these flyers call
Friendly competition starting from South
Lake Tahoe earlier this week all of a
sudden it's like whoa
the ground is like ways away from me now
with views like this that long time
Flyers like Trevor Steele hope Moore can
see if they're down or up rather you can
actually fly and enjoy this aircraft and
go and enjoy Aviation which is typically
very expensive and difficult to get into
this is not
all right these paragliders own their
own equipment which can cost up to
fifteen thousand dollars and if you
really want and you can also rent it
which starts at about two hundred
dollars with a tour guide and I know
that we were talking about how we just
did the pair of gliding right and over
water and that was great maybe we can
take one of those into the Greek
Festival this weekend